Costigan Breslin its Fanta pad welcome
to kill a hatter in the image we play
this game a while ago and now he came
out with a full version
look at that kitty isn't that Kitty
adorable
all right so the game is telling me to
knock objects to the flow holy [ __ ] I
can jump like a mouse [ __ ] up rich booth
damn I can jump so much better now okay
I know how to play oh my god
oh my god get ready [ __ ]
yeah that's bread bleach what at seven
more items oh my head [ __ ] off with you
okay what do we got we got football and
painting how am I gonna get the painting
out ha stupid Pig that painting is
beautiful why did I do that
hey I go that's how we do it jump in the
box to continue oh that's the cutest
thing I'm sorry I'm a bit emotional I
need some exercise those humans will pay
all I wanted in life was to be a [ __ ]
kitty cat is that's so hard it [ __ ]
is that so hard understand walk and poke
too
I can [ __ ] join a douche line army or
some [ __ ] ha ha ha I can push them out
like this hey robot brofist Hey I poke
you that's right socks one to me zero
two socks holy [ __ ] there's so much [ __ ]
here why is making a mess so satisfying
they need to come out with this game in
like VR mode or some [ __ ] what is this
oh my god it spins oh my god it spins
totally paper roll can I make it spin
yes yes ha ha ha ha and then I told the
paper whoever is the owner of this cat
oh man it can I flame myself dead cat on
this stove that's not funny that's not
funny
no I fell in out of me oh my god I feel
like I haven't made a [ __ ] joke yet
whoever owns this cat is a [ __ ]
No okay well it will come to me don't
worry oh man I'm really trying [ __ ]
hard here
man I really don't know why it's like
you can't stop see cats are just
[ __ ] dogs would never do this [ __ ]
right Edgar you would never do this
right right
I guess way too lazy to do anything
oh so if I bite these objects oh my God
look at that face more upgrades yes oh
go on
I'm gonna be [ __ ] super kitty 2012
look at that I'm sweating like a boss
catnip if it's really cat nip it I was
good on three 6000 I don't even know
what's going on man oh it's over I was
[ __ ] sweet a [ __ ] we're done you got a
tan Bruce better hurry happenin can we
enter the fridge oh yes we can
oh my god it's filled with [ __ ] why
would you just keep a bunch of stuff in
this drawer thing [ __ ] stupid owner
ass [ __ ]
Betty's never gotten any [ __ ] there it
is there was the joke just in time [ __ ]
don't what L can't dance ah did I just
fail I think I did
I like how I um look photos in the game
you know I can just go to google and
search cat images like what's the
[ __ ] point
Oh images are [ __ ] better be some
sweet-ass [ __ ] pictures later that's
all I'm saying alright okay this room is
clean
I mean dirty but look at this [ __ ]
room oh man I almost feel bad almost it
wasn't me I swear to god it wasn't me
look what are you doing to me look don't
touch me when I'm not sleeping alright
let's let's take a look at it the
proposed that we online alright that's
yes oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah man
well Scarlett is a [ __ ] [ __ ] they
should just made the game about this
this is way better the [ __ ] are you
doing in there Harley get the [ __ ] off
Harley you're not a cat Harley
alright press it looks like a knife the
end of that episode there it's a game
about being a [ __ ] cat I don't know
what jealousy wants but that's it leave
a comment about cat [ __ ] and I'll see
you in the next one